hey how's it going I'm destiny and I'm
gonna crash hi my name is usman and I'm
in first grade hi my name is Linden and
I'm in third grade hi my name is TJ and
I'm in fourth grade
hey I'm destiny and I haven't been in
school for I'm not gonna say how many
years but more years and they are old
my relationship with math is a love-hate
relationship I actively avoided taking
math classes and that's all I ended up
in journalism I'm good at math I think
I'm gonna be my competitor they don't
remember down much of their childhood
but they know I love the Kurama pug so
don't forget hold them exactly yeah
[Music]
no peeking is it 9
[Music]
so right in 5+5 one for my Wow thank you
oh I'll just wipe it with my finger or
[Music]
the difference they're taking away yeah
they get very happily I'm saying this
not confidently oh well she did show
hers I'll let you take that one
you turned her around quicker than I
could now you take it oh you are my best
friend ever
and you oh you're my best friend too
I've made a new best friend can I ask
you what a vertice is yeah it's the
points of the square like do you know
that 104 we're doing it backwards why
math is hard for words
I need to write out equations you are on
it because she taught me what birdy sees
are there three I only got this because
of you
[Music]
well you did great high five he also
taught me something so oh that one got
it hey how's it going okay good i'm
destinee it's nice to meet you
Linden okay are you ready for our math
quiz today I don't know the I was like
no the three it's not a one it might be
it to there wait six minus and this is
what grade 59 whoa you're quick you're
quick on your toes me on the other hand
practice
um I got it 107 oh yeah oh wait no what
so three plus five plus eight so okay
Wow Wow I got two four corners equals a
dollar
oh I got it
is it 200 to one team I know but then I
came back I know I know that's why I
came back it's been 20 I feel like that
should count for something right
okay so 12 so 14 she did the math out
loud it helped what is what y'all are
leaving me hang in why are y'all so
intense what is in this cafeteria food
[Music]
hi I'm destiny hi I'm TJ hi TJ what
grade are you in for for it mmm all
right let's put out put it in this is
like are you smarter than the fourth
grade yeah and I don't want the Internet
to notify you all right let's go let's
get into it
are you good at math yeah yeah you
cheated
okay seven I said seven but I was like
one-third okay I need a third of 21 okay
one is three times one a okay answer to
everything
forty-two right yeah number one oh I'll
tell you I'm you time to get Barry these
toys look like they were vete like
Europe oh you think yeah like what is
this blah just no longer care about them
a doubt for something else
I don't know I was gonna put something
about into the last time is it 6:00 okay
I just said something for I don't like
this game
I don't like a game at all
3:59 also sorry it's so tiny who I could
do addition I need to add up bills 572
you know why I wrote I wrote six
thousand seven and I forgot to regroup
the one we root you know what are you
thinking no well we grouping is when you
have like say for example seven plus
five you need you need to put the like
the last digit and then put the one
that's regrouping oh that's regrouping
[Laughter]
okay okay eight six oh I thought I was
coming up with a single digit I'm not
adding her and that's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
my brain is exhausted there was so many
questions I learned about I think
vertices a lot the children came in
super intense I think everybody wanted
to devour me oh man I won't do this
again this was cute the kids are great
love it but next time I'll like sign up
for English or something
[Music]
you
[Music]
you